Привіт, любі десятикласники!
Рада вітати вас на уроці української мови.
Сьогодні ми з вами пригадаємо
морфологію, визначимо морфологічну норму,
морфологічну помилку і акцентуємо
увагу на іменнику як частині мови.
Який розділ науки про мову
називається морфологія?
Далі дивіться на екран!
Ви бачите зображення
десяти пальців. І не даремно,
адже в українській
мові десять частин мови.
Шість самостійних, три
службових і один вигук.
Поговоримо більш докладно
про самостійні частини мови.
Перша частина мови - це іменник.
Іменник означає особу або предмет
і відповідає на питання хто? що?
Далі дивіться на екран!
Числівник - позначає
кількість або порядок при лічбі,
і вдповідає на питання
скільки? котрий?
увага на екран
Займенник є четвертою частиною мови,
і відповідає на ті ж самі питання,
що і іменник, прикметник та числівник,
П'ята частина мови - це дієслово.
Дієслово означаю дію або стан,
а також ознаку за дією.
Традиційні питання дієслова -
що робити? що зробити?
Шоста самостійна частина
мови - це прислівник.
Прислівник позначає ознаку
дії, ознаку ознаки, стан предмета,
і відповідає на питання -
як? де? куди? коли? звідки? яким чином?
яким способом? навіщо? чому? наскільки?
і так далі.
Службових частин мови три.
Службові частини мови,
на відміну від самостійних,
не мають лексичного значення,
не відповідають на питання
і не є членами речення. Службові
частини мови лише для чогось слугують.
Прийменник слугує для зв'язку
слів у реченні або у словосполученні.
Недарма він називається прийменником -
тобто ПРИ-іменником, ПРИ-займенником.
Сполучник сполучає однорідні члени
речення або частини складного речення.
Частка слугує для утворення граматичних
форм або надає відтінки в значеннях.
Окремою частиною мови є вигук.
Виражає почуття, волевиявлення.
Дивіться на екран!
Ці всі слов є вигуками.
Вивчаючи морфологію, варто звернути увагу
на морфологічну норму
та морфологічну помилку.
увага на екран
Запитання для глядачів!
Правильна відповідь Г. Саме, у варіанті
Г допущено морфологічну помилку.
Іменник нежить в українській
мові чоловічого роду.
Тому, правильно говорити легкий нежить.
Найтиповішими
морфологічними помилками є такі:
Уживання одного роду замість іншого.
Неправильно казати густа шампунь,
правильно - густий шампунь.
Адже, іменник шампунь — чоловічого роду.
Другою морфологічною помилкою
є вживання однієї відмінкової
форми замість іншої.
Неправильно говорити
— по вулицЯМ, по вікнАМ.
Закінчення в українській мові АМ,
ЯМ не вживаються в місцевому відмінку.
Правильно говорити —
По вуляцЯХ, по вікнАХ.
Третя помилка — відмінювання
невідмінюваних слів.
Якщо слово не відмінюється, то
ніяких відмінкових форм не може бути.
Неправильно говорити: на авті, у метрі.
В українській мові ці
слова є незмінюваними.
Правильно — на авто, у метро.
Четвертою морфологічною
помилкою є порушення
норм утворення ступенів
порівняння прикметників.
Неправильно говорити:
більш цікавіший урок.
Правильно: більш цікавий урок.
Ми не повинні змішувати дві
форми утворення прикметників:
просту — цікавіший урок, та
складену — більш цікавий урок.
Запам'ятайте, що прикметники
вищого і найвищого ступенів порівняння
складеної форми утворюються
додаванням слів більш, менш,
або найбільш, найменш до
початкової форми прикметника.
Тому правильно говорити: більш
цікавий, менш корисний та ін.
Неправильно говорити: самий добрий друг.
В українській мові слово
самий не вживається.
Хіба що - це займенник.
Правильно: найдобріший друг.
Вживаємо префікс най-,
замість калькованого самий.
П'ятою морфологічною помилкою
є вживання закінчень
м'якої групи замість твердої.
Якщо прикметник твердої групи,
тобто його основа закінчується
на твердий приголосний,
то закінчення буде -ий
Правильно - природнИЙ стан, а не природнІЙ
Шостою морфологічною помилкою є
неправильне творення форм числівників.
Неправильно: семистам,
сорокам, чотирмастами...
Правильно: семисот,
сорока, чотирмастами...
Звертаю вашу увагу, що в
числівниках на позначення сотень
відмінюються обидві частини і
в родовому відмінку буде -сот.
Числівники сорок, дев'яносто,
сто у всіх відмінках, окрім називного,
мають закінчення -ам. А числівник
чотириста в орудному відмінку
має форму чотирмастами, без вживання Ь.
Сьомою морфологічною помилкою є вживання
дійсного способу дієслова
замість наказового.
Неправильно говорити пішли на вулицю,
правильно - ходімо на вулицю.
Ходімо гуляти, ходімо відпочивати...
Восьмою морфологічною помилкою
є використання частки давай/давайте
для творення форм наказового способу.
Неправильно: давайте
писати, давайте читати.
Правильно: читаймо,
пишімо, слухаймо, вивчаймо...
Завдання для глядачів.
Морфологічну помилку допущену в рядку:
Дивіться на екран!
Правильною є відповідь Б, помилку
допущено саме в цьому словосполученні.
Сьогодні більш докладно
поговоримо про іменник.
Дивіться на екран!
Лексико-граматичні категорії іменника:
іменники є назви істот і назви неістот.
Істоти відповідають на
питання хто?, неістоти - що?
Іменники бувають
загальними і власними назвами.
Загальні назви пишемо з
малої літери, власні - з великої.
Але не завжди легко визначити
- іменник істота чи неістота,
тому що виникають труднощі: хто або що.
Істоти й неістоти.
Увага на екран!
Неістотами слід вважати - назви предметів,
явищ, конкретних і абстрактних понять -
хустка, зірка, магазин, біологія.
Назви сукупності людей чи тварин -
табун, гурт, рій, сотня, армія,
і назви мікроогранізмів - бактерія, вірус.
Граматичні категорії.
Рід - в іменника він може бути чоловічий,
жіночий, середній, а також спільний.
Число - однина або множина,
і відмінок.
Іменник має сім відмінків
Увага на екран!
І ще є сьомий - кличній відмінок. Він
відповідає на ті ж питання, що і називний,
і лише іменник має кличний відмінок.
Називний відмінок - це прямий,
а всі інші відмінки є непрямими.
Рід іменника.
Увага на екран!
Ця жінка, ця хата, ця рука
В іменниках середнього роду можна
підставити це -
це тіло, це весло, це сонце
Спільний рід визначається
залежно від контексту -
цей плакса, а може бути - ця плакса.
Про роди іменників, а також труднощі
щодо його визначення в певних словах
поговоримо на наступному нашому уроці.
Число іменника.
Увага на екран!
Лише в однині вживаються збірні іменники -
дрібнота, дітвора, коріння, студентство,
назви абстрактних понять -
патріотизм, завзяття, запал
Назви речовин - бензин, молоко, власні
назви - Україна, Київ, Чигирин та ін.
Увага на екран!
назви речовин - дріжджі,
вершки, макарони, парфуми,
власні назви - Карпати,
Чернівці, Альпи, Суми, Афіни.
І назви предметів парної чи симетричної
будови - окулярі, граблі, ковзани, ножиці.
Синтаксична роль.
Іменник може бути
будь-яким членом речення.
Розгляньмо на прикладах.
В ролі підмета іменник
вживається найчастіше.
Успішний учень багато працює.
В ролі присудка. Іван
Іваненко успішний учень.
Тобто, є успішний учень.
В ролі додатка. Я знаю успішних учнів.
В ролі означення. Учні
пишуть есе у зошиті в клітинку.
У зошиті (якому?) в клітинку.
У ролі обставини. Успішні учні
навчаються в школі та вдома.
Навчаються (де?) в школі та вдома.
Домашне завдання
увага на екран
Лунає дзвінок, отже, настав час прощатися.
До нових зустрічей!